Speaker 1: Let's go next to Alejandro from
San Antonio, Texas.
You're on the air.
Speaker 2: Oh, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Also, it's been about two years since I last
time I called Wow.
When they come back.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
I'm so glad to have you back.
Speaker 2: So about they are continuing to
do your show.
Speaker 1: I know the show has not yet.
The show has not yet failed and collapsed,
much to the chagrin of many in the audience.
Speaker 2: Definitely.
Yeah.
One day I got to see it.
All right, my question today for you is, is
the world going to get a little bit more worse,
like more worse off politically now?
Would covid necessarily with everything going
on in the Middle East?
Speaker 1: You're saying, is the world going
to be worse off for a while?
Speaker 2: Yeah, like, I'm not talking about
it because right now the focus is on America
with Biden being the president, Trump gone
like the drudge of it, mingering still.
But really, everything going on globally seems
very terrifying.
You know, it's kind of it's kind of like we're
sheltered in a way,
Speaker 1: there's no question about that.
I mean, the problem is that there are so many
different issues, background issues and acute
issues.
There are people who would hear your question
and they would say, you know, the geopolitics
really doesn't matter if we don't deal with
climate, if we don't deal with climate in
10, 15, 20, 25 years, we're screwed.
Right.
That would be a very macro perspective.
Someone else might say, you know, the real
issue is this push towards right wing nationalism
in the United States and in Europe and to
some degree even in Latin America, that someone
would focus on that.
It's such a on a planet of seven to what are
we close to eight billion people now with
so many macro and micro problems to deal with
foreign policy, the pandemic?
I don't know.
I mean, you know, the Steven Pinker approach,
which has been much criticized, is a very
long term macro view, which is the percentage
of people embroiled in a war is down.
Life expectancy is up.
Infant mortality is down, terrorism is down,
violent crime is down.
The number of people living in abject poverty
is down.
That's the Steven Pinker approach.
There's a ton of people who are very critical
of that because they say, well, Steven Pinker
is considering circumstances today in the
same context as circumstances 200 years ago.
We are so much more advanced right now that
our standards should not be to compare how
things are today to 200 years ago.
Does that make sense?
Yes.
So it's very much perspective and philosophy
based.
But taking all of that into consideration
for me, I think that the geopolitical issues
won't be resolved anytime soon, the macro
geopolitical issues, but that hopefully we
have competent enough governments to keep
them at a low enough level, that technological
progress can continue, that biomedical research
progress can continue, and that we deal with
the climate issue.
So I would put myself at like a cautious optimism,
like 51 to 49.
I don't know.
It's a small margin.
Yeah, my pleasure.
Thank you for your call.
It's a good question.
I mean, it's it's a big picture question,
but sometimes digging into the big picture
is a good thing.
Why don't we go next?
Wow.
There are a lot of people hoping to get on
today.
Let's go next to Toby from Kansas.
Toby, you're on the air.
Yeah, you're on the air, Tony.
Speaker 2: Hi, David.
I just had a quick question about if you have
any thoughts of what was going on in the U.K.
elections last week.
Speaker 1: No, I have not been following it.
No, you tell me what's been going on.
Speaker 2: It seems like Pakistan has kind
of ruined the outlook for labor for the next
Speaker 1: couple of years.
OK, what
Speaker 2: happened?
Well, he didn't really have a concrete manifesto
played out.
Oh, sorry.
I'm losing my job right now.
Speaker 1: So you're losing your Uber.
Oh, my goodness, they left, OK?
Wow, what a what a day.
Just a lot of people very, very much embroiled
in different things.
Why don't we go next to let's go to Marshall
from New Jersey.
Marshall, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: I David, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can hear you.
Speaker 2: And David, I just had a pretty
simple question about in a presidential election
scenario in which we in which we see another
split between the Electoral College result
and the popular vote result.
Yes.
Could something like that trigger enough of
a backlash so that we see a speeded up abolishing
the Electoral College?
Speaker 1: No.
And you know, the reason I say that, Marshall,
is we had that situation in the year 2000
and nothing changed.
And then we had that situation again in now.
So obviously, we had it in 2016.
Did we have it in like in 2004?
Did Kerry get more votes?
Now, I don't remember.
Anyway, the point we're sorry.
What was that?
Speaker 2: I think Bush won both popular and
electoral, you know, in 04.
Speaker 1: OK, yeah.
The point is, no, it's been 20 years this
has been going on and it doesn't seem to listen
for that for as long as one party benefits
from the system.
We have and Republicans benefit right now
from that.
They will resist changing it.
So, no, I'm not optimistic that if it is,
just one more time is going to make it change.
No, I don't see it.
And I still continue to think that the best
path to effectively eliminating the Electoral
College is the national popular vote interstate
compact, where you don't do it via some change
to the Constitution.
Just enough states agree to give their electors
to whoever wins the popular vote.
I still see that as the most direct path.
Speaker 2: All right, David, I thank you so
much for taking my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure, Marshal from New Jersey.
Great to hear from you.
I'm going to take a quick break, but don't
hang up if you want to talk to me, because
I'm going right back to the phones
in
a moment.